c'est ce que je réalise avec jean de
manger un autre combat on ma vie qui est
celui de la sécurité routière s'agit
d'un projet de loi qui vise à mettre en
place des tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
nous ne céderons rien en face au
terrorisme islamiste
les mots d' emmanuel macron après qu'une
fonctionnaire de police a été tué lors
d'une attaque au couteau faux
commissariat de rambouillet dans les
yvelines
l'assaillant a été abattu par d'autres
agents le parquet national anti
terroriste s'est saisi d'une enquête
le premier ministre et le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est rendu sur les lieux du
drame
[Musique]
nouvelle la mobilisation aujourd'hui
contre la réforme de l'assurance chômage
elle doit entrer en vigueur le 1er
juillet manifestations partout en france
à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
il dénonce le nouveau mode de calcul des
allocations et des recours juridiques
devraient être déposées avant la mi mai
[Musique]
emmanuel macron et ses homologues des
pays du sahel promettent leur soutien à
la junte militaire au tchad le tchad où
se déroulait ce vendredi les obsèques du
président idriss deby c'est l'un de ses
fils qui a pris les rênes du pays
la france est attentive à la stabilité
du pays allié stratégique dans la lutte
contre les djihadistes dans la région
[Musique]
un bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france un homme abattu
après avoir tué au couteau une
fonctionnaire de police
les faits se sont déroulés en début
d'après-midi dans l'entrée du
commissariat de rambouillet dans les
yvelines le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin on demande aux préfets
de renforcer la sécurité aux abords des
commissariats et des brigades de
gendarmerie il s'est rendu sur les lieux
du drame au côté du premier ministre
jean castex qu'on écoute tout de suite
mais première fois ses ventes à la
famille de cette fonctionnaire et à tous
ses proches
je me suis rendu immédiatement sur place
avec gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur pour apporter tout notre
soutien aux policiers et fonctionnaires
du commissariat de rambouillet comme
vous l'imaginez très durement éprouvées
par ces faits et je tiens à rendre
hommage aux fonctionnaires de police qui
ont immédiatement neutralisé
l'auteur des faits une nouvelle fois le
département des yvelines est mis à rude
épreuve des attaques terroristes
puisque nous avons tous en mémoire
l'odieux attentat de magnanville en 2016
et plus récemment l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit je voudrais dire à l'ensemble des
françaises et des français
combien notre détermination à lutter
contre le terrorisme sous toutes ses
formes est plus que jamais intact le
parquet national anti terroriste s'est
saisi de l'enquêté
les précisions de notre envoyé spécial
david khalifa le mode opératoire les
mots qu'il a prononcés à lorsqu'il est
passé à l'acte allah ouakbar confirme la
piste terroriste le procureur de la
république s'est exprimé juste après le
premier ministre pour donner l les
premiers éléments de l'enquète est
justement expliqué la saisie du parquet
national anti terroriste écouter le
parquet national anti terroriste s'est
saisi du crime qui a été commis en début
d'après midi ici à rambouillet
les raisons de cette saisine sont les
suivantes en premier le déroulement même
des faits qui comprend des éléments de
repérage également la réalisation
d'effets modalités mêmes du crime la
personne de la victime mais aussi les
propos tenus par l'auteur au moment de
la réalisation des faits ce sont
l'ensemble de ces éléments qui nous ont
décidé à accepter notre saisine ce que
nous avons donc décidé ce que l'on sait
pour le moment de l'assaillant un
tunisien de 36 ans arrivé en france en
2009 en situation irrégulière il a
obtenu un titre de séjour grâce à un
emploi à deux chauffeurs livreurs qui
expirera fin à 2021 à il habitait depuis
peu à rambouillet son domicile a été
perquisitionné se trouve à une dizaine
de minutes du commissariat ils auraient
repéré les lieux en amont de son acte
barbare en tout cas l'émotion est
palpable ici importe où les rivera qu'on
a pu interroger rambouillet une commune
sans problème une commune plutôt
tranquille est la police nationale a
rendu un vibrant hommage à stéphanie
cette fonctionnaire de police
morte à l'âge de 49 ans et mère de deux
enfants du côté des syndicats la colère
vient elle remplacer la tristesse c'est
le cas de françois bersani secrétaire
général gp de la police ait des yvelines
qui appelle le gouvernement à prendre
ses responsabilités
le premier sentiment là que qui va
habiter tous les policiers de ce
département les policiers de ce
commissariat de rambouillet les
policiers français dans leur ensemble et
bien oui c'est le chagrin c'est la peine
perdre une femme de 45 ans deux enfants
une mère de famille administrative qui
travaillent dans ce commissariat comme
agent d'accueil c'est terrible c'est
terrible c'est de ne pas en plus la
première fois que notre commissariat
enfin que le nôtre département plutôt
est en deuil et nous avons perdu un
couple de collègues en 2016 à
magnanville
jessica et jean baptiste nous avons un
professeur d'histoire assassiné l'an
dernier aujourd'hui un pôle une
policière dans ce commissariat de
rambouillet aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
après le chagrin après les mois il
scella la colère je pense qu'il va
prendre place à savoir que la sécurité a
été renforcée devant tous les
commissariats et toutes les gendarmeries
de france
l enquête de son côté suit son cours
pour rappel elle a été confiée
conjointement à la direction centrale de
la police judiciaire et à la dgsi un
nouveau drame donc dans les yvelines qui
a fait réagir la classe politique
regardez c'est un choc terrible pour
rambouillet pour les yvelines une
nouvelle fois endeuiller les mots sont
faibles face à l'horreur et à la
sidération qui nous étreint tous chaque
jour nos forces de l'ordre mettent leur
vie en jeu pour nous ça suffit d'avoir
la mémoire courte
hommage à la policière tuée en début
d'après-midi au commissariat de
rambouillet la menace envers nos forces
de l'ordre est omniprésente est à son
paroxysme je pense à sa famille et ses
collègues nos forces de l'ordre
encore une fois prise pour cible un
fonctionnaire de police a été
sauvagement assassinée à rambouillet je
lui rends hommage et m'associe à la
douleur de sa famille ses proches et ses
collègues horreur en apprenant le décès
de la policière après l'attaqué au
couteau du commissariat de rambouillet
attaqué un uniforme c'est s'en prendre à
la république entière toute la lumière
doit être faite rapidement sur cet acte
odieux
les sentiments oscille entre tristesse
et colère ce jour en france
une policière viennent d'être tués dans
un commissariat à rambouillet je pense à
sa famille à ses collègues mes mots sont
dérisoires
l'action des policiers quant à elle
aussi essentielle qui éprouvante
actualité de ce vendredi en france
marquée par une mobilisation nationale
contre la réforme de l'assurance-chômage
mobilisation à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats dont la cgt et solidaires
il dénonce à un nouveau mode de calcul
des locaux des allocations moins
favorable aux demandeurs d'emploi qui
alterne régulièrement en période de
chômage d'activité à paris le cortège
s'est élancé de la place d'italie
direction la place de la bastille compte
rendu de notre reporter katia technique
aujourd'hui plusieurs milliers de
manifestants ont défilé entre la place
d'italie et la place de la bastille
contre la réforme de l'assurance chômage
ils ont répondu à l'appel de la cgt de
solidaires et de nombreuses
organisations de très nombreux
manifestants artistes intermittents
s'étaient joints au cortège dans une
ambiance festive ils ont réclamé la
réouverture des salles et évidemment la
prolongation de l'année blanche alors un
mot sur cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui va entrer en vigueur le 1er
juillet eh bien elle va les et tout
particulièrement les travailleurs les
plus précaires les chômeurs à temps
partiel comme par exemple les
saisonniers les intérimaires les guides
conférenciers
ils vont perdre jusqu'à 17% de leur
indemnisation même problème de baisse
indemnisation pour les personnes qui ont
certes travailler mais qui était avant
cela en congé maternité maladie ou
encore chômeurs à temps partiel alors la
ministre du travail les abeilles borgne
a eu beau proposer des rectifications et
bien les manifestants ne décolère pas je
vous propose de les écouter ils ont
ebuzz drastiquement les allocations
chômage ils baissent drastiquement
l'intermittence l'obtention des droits
au chômage à l'indemnisation l'obtention
en tout ils tapent tout pendant ce temps
il recule surtout les problématiques
environnementales
bref enfin toutes leurs actions est un
non sens et il ne travaille pas pour les
citoyens qui ont voté pour eux mêmes on
ne vote pas que on ne travaille pas que
pour ses électeurs quand on est
président on est président du pays
entier et là c'est pas le cas et voilà
donc cette nation au chômage n'a pour
l'instant le seul régime général et est
en train de nous de nous tuer à petit
feu sur le fait qu' on est en train de
perdre tous les droits qu'on a acquis
depuis des années on est en train de les
perdre du jour au lendemain uniquement
parce qu'on veut faire les économies sur
le dos alors on veut bien discuter après
locaux vides
le problème c'est que ça se passe en
plein creux vide au moment où déjà on
travaille pas ça fait un an que nous
sommes au chômage
je suis maître d'hôtel on a une équipe
de
depuis leur maître d'hôtel certains
mettent fin à leurs jours parce qu'ils
ont plus de droits au chômage depuis
depuis le mois de mars
quelques partis politiques comme europe
ecologie les verts le parti de gauche la
france insoumis s'étaient joints au
cortège vous propose d'écouter et les
coquerelles député insoumis non il n'ya
qu'une correction possible c'est qu'elle
est la reprenne
voilà et qu'elle ne s'applique pas c'est
la seule correction parce qu'on connaît
un petit peu l'heureux leur stratégie un
coup ya une montée comme ça ils nous ont
fait pas sa part sur la loi sécurité
globale il avait commencé à dire en
l'article 24 on va le dire on va
discuter on va le refaire
bilan vous avez vu il a été appliqué tel
quel quasi bon donc là c'est pareil nous
la seule chose qu'on qu'on souhaite
entendre c'est qu'elle retient projet
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
journée de mobilisation à noter que fo
et la cgt ont déposé des recours devant
le conseil d'état pour demander
l'annulation du décret ainsi sur la
réforme est aux premières loges donc de
cette journée de même but de
mobilisation le monde de la culture du
côté de lyon manifestation à l'appel du
collectif occupons 69 qui investit
depuis plusieurs semaines le théâtre
national populaire et l'opéra de la
ville
percussions et concerts étaient au
programme aujourd'hui
selon la préfecture du rhône six cents
personnes ont répondu présent 2000 selon
la cgt s'est mobilisé contre la réforme
de l'assurance chômage parce qu'on ait
beaucoup de fraîcheur
énormément de précaires dans nos
professions
et cette assurance est cette réforme
elle va mettre à mal beaucoup de
beaucoup de bien de gains pour beaucoup
de gens et
de gagner notre croûte entre deux entre
deux contrats précaires
qui pleuvent qu'il vente qu'il neige on
est dehors et
on n'a aucune reconnaissance en fait que
ce soit au niveau humain et que ce soit
au niveau salarial
parce que pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée avec bac + 5
tu payes et 1300 euros où est ce que je
veux dire dans les cités de la précarité
il ya cette réforme qui est absolument
ignobles qui va être mise en oeuvre à
partir du 1er juillet qui a été décidé
par décret il ya deux semaines et qui va
rendre plus difficile l'accès à
l'allocation chômage qui va baisser les
allocations des travailleurs disent
continue donc dans ce mouvement là c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est au coeur
de cible de ce qu'on revendique en
sachant qu'on veut pas s'arrêter là
parce que l'assurance chômage avant
cette réforme elle était déjà pas
satisfaisante
il y avait six chômeurs sur dix qui
était pas indemnisé l'indemnisation
moyenne c'était 900 euros 900 euros
c'est bien en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté on vit pas avec ça dernier
week-end en france avant la rentrée des
maternelles et des primaires les élèves
reprendront comme prévu le chemin de
l'école lundi
première étape vers la levée des
restrictions déconfinement progressif
annoncé si la situation sanitaire le
permet car l'exécutif se montre prudent
pierrier de mazarine
c'est la première étape vers un
troisième déconfinement lundi les
écoliers feront leur retour dans les
salles de classe une rentrée encadré par
un protocole sanitaire stricte et un
renforcement massif des tests suivront
ensuite les collégiens et les lycéens
qui pourront retrouver leur
rétablissement
le 3 mai prochain c'est indispensable
les enfants ont besoin d'écoles les
privés d'école a des conséquences
éducatives sanitaires psychologiques
le but est que les enfants français est
une année d'école la plus normale
possible
le 3 mai une date clé qui devrait aussi
marquer la levée des restrictions de
déplacement en journée sur le territoire
en revanche le couvre-feu restera en
vigueur jusqu'à nouvel ordre indiqué
jean castex le premier ministre qui
reste également prudent sur la
réouverture des établissements
accueillant du public nous pourront
lever les contraintes de déplacement en
journée est envisagée sous réserve de
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
un nouveau train de réouverture autour
de la mi mai qui pourrait commencer par
les commerces certaines activités
culturelles et sportives et les
terrasses cette liste n'est pas
définitivement fixée
elle sera assortie de conditions
particulières le cas échéant je le
disais territorialisée qui évolueront au
fil des étapes
beaucoup d'incertitudes demeurent alors
que le niveau de l'épidémie reste élevée
tout comme la pression hospitalière près
de 6000 personnes sont toujours en
réanimation pour un total de 30 mille
patients hospitalisés en exécutent
l'exécutif qu'ils étaient préoccupés par
les variants du corps un virus alors
pour limiter leur propagation sur le sol
français
des restrictions vont être mises en
place concernant certains déplacements à
l'international
ainsi à partir de demain tous les
passagers en provenance du brésil d'inde
du chili d'afrique du sud et d'argentine
se verront imposer
un isolement de dix jours ceux venant de
guyane également la liste des pays
concernés pourra évoluer si nécessaire
souligne le gouvernement
1 ce samedi marquera aussi le coup
d'envoi des injections avec john seine
vaccins du laboratoire américain johnson
and johnson quatrième autorisé en france
les français de plus de 55 ans pourront
recevoir ce sérum qui ne nécessite lui
qu'une seule injection
les deux cent mille premières doses
seront livrées aux pharmacies aux
médecins et aux infirmiers libéraux
l'exécutif qui a tenté de rassurer sur
astrazeneca hier soir pointé du doigt
après de rares cas de caillots sanguins
le premier ministre a rappelé s'être
fait vacciner avec ce sérum son ministre
de la santé avance en lui que le risque
d'avoir une thrombose et est 50 fois
plus élevé en prenant un vol
transatlantique
ce vendredi c'est l'agencé européenne
des médicaments qui a déclaré que les
bénéfices du vaccin astrazeneca à
augmenter avec l'âge et continuer de
l'emporter sur les risques
le coc vide qui impacte un peu plus
encore les étudiants en première année
de médecine déjà confrontés à une
réforme de leur cursus témoignages tout
de suite de north n 1 qualifié en direct
avec nous
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france 2 est étudiante en première année
de médecine cette réforme vous y être
confronté depuis plusieurs mois et vous
dénoncer une injustice expliquez nous
alors oui du coup bah je suis en
première année en passe donc s'appelle
passe maintenant puisque avance ap ap
acs donc on est confronté à une nouvelle
réforme
nous roulons une réforme qui n'est pas
préparée apparemment puisque ben moi je
suis à marseille et on et 1600 pour 193
places en médecine
vingt-et-une en dentaire 6 en maïeutique
je crois entre comme ça
donc bon voilà les chiffres parlent
d'eux mêmes c'est catastrophique c'est
scandaleux parce que quand je travaille
de 8 heures à 22 heures tous les jours
depuis septembre jusqu'à là j'ai passé
mon concours en le 19 20 21 avril et
qu'on te dit que ben peut-être que tu
vas pas passer parce que ben c'est la
mauvaise année et que l'année prochaine
ils auront plus de place que nous et les
années précédentes il y en avait plus
que nous bon c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué c'est dur de se dire que dany
la mauvaise année en fait parce que
l'enjeu de la réforme de la première
année de médecine s'étaient pourtant de
supprimer le fameux numerus clausus le
nombre de places limité déterminée par
l'état pour qu'on comprenne mais en quoi
est ce que cette première année est
particulièrement compliqué pour vous
qu'est ce qu'elle change la réforme dans
le cursus de la première année en fait
un beau parcours
les années précédentes en passer tu
arrives et tu faisais ta première année
et si tout raté battu redoublé et en
général les gens ils passaient en 2e
année parce que ben il avait enfin leur
deuxième année en tant que double ans il
passé parce qu'ils avaient l'avantagé
aucunement qui connaissait pas le le
programme et c'est le truc c'est que la
réforme elle part d'un bon d'un bon
sentiment dans le sens où elle voulait
supprimer cette injustice entre doublant
et primes ans le problème c'est que ben
il faut préparer cette forme et il ya
toujours une année de transition et le
problème c'est que ben l'année dernière
les primes en de l'année dernière belle
et redouble cette année donc nous on
arrive on a aussi notre caucus en même
temps et on doit se partager nos places
en gros voilà c'est ça le problème
cet indice et cuba on doit partager nos
classes avec les doubles en plein dedans
hercules en droit au redoublement c'est
leur droit et nous qui expérimente dans
la peau la réforme pour la première fois
et qui du coup en moins de place des
informations on a eu que la la j'ai eu
du monde mais russie à un mois un mois
avant le concours alors qu'on a des
spécialités à préparer donc je suis
désolé mais on a besoin de savoir où
nous placer par rapport à notre
classement pour savoir si bas ont peu
près par les dentaires sont préparés
médecine etc
c'est des matières qui sont différentes
et on a eu le nombre de places un moment
avant le concours
lorsqu'elle a été présentée la réforme
lorsqu'elle a été présentée elle était
censée vous aider vous avez le sentiment
finalement que c'est l'effet inverse qui
se produit aujourd'hui bon clairement en
fait là on n'a pas les bienvenus pour
les années d'après en fait nous avons
subi la transition elle a été clairement
mal comparé si elle n'avait pas et si
elle avait bien préparé comme à paris
ils ont eu à un numéro qui a été
augmenté de 30% en trois ans et non nous
on a eu un numéro qui a été augmenté de
6% à 12% pour les plus chanceux et ça en
fait c'est le nombre de places qui
bloque le manque d'information parce que
moi personnellement dans ma fac on a eu
deux nouvelles matières on savait pas
comment les préparer les professeurs
n'ont pas donné de qcm pour nous dire
comment nous préparer et c'est non c'est
d'abord d'une bonne intention mais ça
aurait pu être meilleur en fait
clairement s'il avait été mieux préparé
bon je pense que le court il n'a pas
assisté aux justes l'impact de cette
crise sanitaire sur le déroulé de vos
études ben moi je vous parce qu'après on
a et on a été confiné mais bon ils ont
mis qu'ils ont bien on passe quelque
chose bien et le streaming
les profs étaient filmés on peut
regarder les coffres après en direct et
c'est la seule chose de bien été mise en
place
du coup avoir celle du confinement en
octobre je crois en novembre ont fait
plus aller à la fac jusqu'au concours et
après le deuxième semestre
union quelque chose c'est qu'on pouvait
aller par semaine ont ils nous
envoyaient notre convocation et on
pouvait aller au cours qui nous disait
ans
que faudrait-il a amélioré l'année
prochaine pour les étudiants qui seront
à votre place dès le mois de septembre
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait améliorer bat
déjà je pense que c'est prévu le nombre
de places voire augmenter ça c'est sûr
qu'il n'y aura pas de double en bon je
sais pas si dans les autres facs ce qui
a été mise en place dans ma fac a été
instaurée parce que je trouve que c'est
un peu différent si on ne l'est pas donc
l'histoire du streaming c'est une très
très bonne idée
après je suis passé avec la crise
sanitaire ça va changer les choses et ce
qu'ils pourront aller en présentiel etc
mais ça serait bien de retourner en
présentiel parce que ben on des
étudiants en médecine la première année
elle est connue tu travailles toute la
journée et ben ça fait toujours une
coupure de pouvoir aller en cours et moi
c'est ce qui manquait en tout cas cette
année c'est que ben les cours de 8h à
12h bas ça me permet de voir autre chose
que mes cours et j'espère que eux au
moins ils ont la chance de pouvoir aller
on en fille et en présentiel et cetera
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
témoigner sur notre antenne noren un
qualifié je rappelle que vous êtes donc
étudiante en première année de médecine
et direction maintenant barcelone qui a
célébré aujourd'hui la sant jordi
la fête des livres et des roses annulé
l'an passé et cette journée et
accompagnent habituellement l'arrivée du
printemps et des beaux jours
une étape de plus vers un retour à la
normalité
alors que la catalogne a décidé
d'assouplir ces mesures de confinement
dès lundi
la correspondance de leslie singh l'art
il souffle un air de fête une légèreté à
barcelone car il faut comprendre que la
sant jordi c'est plus qu'un événement
c'est une véritable institution en
catalogne
cette tradition se déroule tous les 23
avril durant une journée et sa marque en
général l'arrivée du printemps le retour
des beaux jours
annulée l'an dernier à cause de la
pandémie
confinement c'est donc une excellente
nouvelle de pouvoir le célébrer à
nouveau cette année notamment pour les
libraires qui font toujours un chiffre
d'affaires record
car habituellement c'est plus d'un
million de livres qui sont vendus à
travers la catalogne alors la mairie de
barcelone a pris des mesures face aux
restrictions sanitaires les stands de
livres et de rose ont été installés aux
quatre coins de la ville afin d' éviter
de concentrer les habitants au même
endroit et ils sont avec accès fermés
afin de pouvoir contrôler l'affluence
à l'intérieur les séances dédicaces
d'auteurs ont été également largement
réduite mais latente jourd'hui reste que
même symbolique pour un retour à la
normalité et les barcelonais sont au
rendez vous ceux que nous avons
rencontrés se disent très contents je
vous propose de les écouter c'est joli
de voir les rues à nouveau pleine en
plus avec une tradition comme la sant
jordi avec des gens qui vendent des
livres et des roses mais ça nous manque
quand même les san jordi des autres
années nous avions tous envie de faire
comme avant en plus il fait soleil
nous avions envie comme avant d'offrir
des buts rennais rose en plus c'est une
pétition catalogue très spécial et très
joli je suis juste venu pour faire un
tour pour voir l'ambiance et ça m'a
vraiment surprise il y à beaucoup de
monde je ne m'y attendais pas on voit
que le beau temps nous accompagne c'est
une sensation très agréable être en
contact avec autant de livres des
nouveaux livres et des écrivains et la
catalogne passera une autre étape lundi
elle a décidé d'assouplir ces
restrictions en supprimant le
confinement territoriales il sera donc
possible de se déplacer à nouveau
librement dans la région
emmanuel macron assure que la france ne
laissera pas remettre en cause la
stabilité du tchad le président français
ait jamais n'a ce vendredi pour assister
aux obsèques nationales du président
idriss deby il est décédé en début de
semaine des suites de blessures reçues
au front lors de combats avec des
rebelles selon l'armée
c'est l'un de ses fils qui a pris à le
pouvoir il est à la tête d'un conseil
militaire pour 18 mois
il s'est engagé à l'issue à des
élections libres et démocratiques
emmanuel macron au promet le soutien de
la france dans cette transition écouter
la france ne laissera jamais personne ne
remettre en cause et ne laissera jamais
personne menacée ni aujourd'hui ni
demain
la stabilité et l'intégrité du tchad
la france sera également là pour faire
vivre sans attendre la promesse d'un
chat apaisé faisant d'une place à
l'ensemble de ses enfants et toutes ses
composantes
la transition aura son rôle à jouer
la stabilité l'inclusion le dialogue la
transition démocratique
et nous sommes et serons à vos côtés et
idriss deby itno était considéré comme
un allié historique de paris sa
disparition préoccupe
quelles conséquences notamment sur la
lutte contre les djihadistes au sahel
le récit de wade bennani et guy marrot 6
les positions françaises sur le qui vive
avec la mort du président idriss deby au
pouvoir depuis plus de trois décennies
paris perd l'un de ses plus vieux alliés
et peut-être son plus important soutien
dans la région alors au milieu des
appels à une transition sans violence
la france n'oublie pas d'invoquer la
continuité dans la lutte anti jihadistes
aujourd'hui une transition commence dans
des conditions dont nous prenons acte
nous espérons qu'elle se déroulera
pacifiquement dans un esprit de dialogue
et de concertation pour aboutir à une
gouvernance civil stable et que la
transition militaire sera la plus brève
possible comme l'a rappelé récemment le
président de la république la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sahel ne
s'arrête pas et aux côtés de l'onu et
des forces du g5 sahel les militaires de
l'opération barkan continue le combat
contre les groupes armés terroristes
l'opération barkan un dispositif de
lutte contre les djihadistes mis en
place au sahel il y à 7 ans sur un
territoire presque aussi vaste que
l'union européenne 5000 militaires
déployés cet avion de chasse 20
hélicoptères 500 blindés pour un total
de près de 130 opérations de combat
jusqu'à présent le tout commandé depuis
cette base de commandement situé dans la
capitale du tchad n'djamena
l'un des trois seuls appui permanent au
sahel paris dispose également dans le
pays de deux bases avancées temporaire
dans le nord et l'est
autant de raisons pour les autorités
françaises de s'inquiéter le sujet du
tchad s'est aussi globalement la
sécurité du sahel et c'est aussi la
sécurité de l'europe
le tchad c'est un pays qui est au
carrefour de beaucoup de menaces
beaucoup de risques à la fois venant de
libye à la fois du nigeria
il faut être très vigilant à la fois sur
la stabilité de la situation aujourd'hui
est ce que le conseil militaire de
transition va assurer la stabilité
l'intégrité du tchad
et puis ensuite comment va-t-il pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre un processus
démocratique et comment par ailleurs
l'armée tchadienne va
elle remplir ses engagements à l'égard
de la force conjointe du sahel il faut
dire que la solide alliance entre paris
et n'djamena tenait notamment au rôle de
la france dans la prise de pouvoir
d'idriss deby en 1990 appuyé par la
direction générale de la sécurité
extérieure la dgse
la france qui a d'ailleurs en retour
assister son allié tchadien dans ses
combats contre les rebelles venus de
libye voici peut-être ce qui explique
les réticences de paris a commenté
l'arrivée de mahamat débit aux affaires
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]